servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute mal mit einer
besonderen variante denn die jungs von
ea games haben mich angefragt ob ich
denn nicht mal deren spiel vorstellen
möchte das heißt shakes and fidget das
ausgraben neues update rausgekommen und
zu diesem anlass hat mich gefragt ob ich
das vorstellen möchte dachte ich mir so
ok browsergame habe ich jetzt schon
länger nicht mehr gespielt habe
die haben gemeint sie würden auch das
hier zur verfügung stellen um es unter
meinen zuschauern zu verlosen das ist
ein ipad mini mit 16 gb
das ist ziemlich nahe des ok wenn die
zuschauer da noch aus davon haben und
dieses ipad gewinnen können da kann man
es auf jeden fall mal machen dazu um das
vieh zu gewinnen schreibt einfach in die
kommentare warum ausgerechnet ihr das
verdient habt dieses ipad zu bekommen
warum ausgerechnet ich es bekommen
solltet da können kreativ sagt irgendwas
ausdenken keine ahnung darüber wie lange
ist schon dabei seid oder warum ihr das
unbedingt braucht oder warum es cool für
euch wäre ich will dann den gewinner aus
und wenn der gewinner ist möchte kann
auch signieren also oder schreiben an
die wurde ich mache die folie ab das ist
noch eine folie eingepackt dass es
nagelneu wurde macht die folie ab und
überschlag auf der hülle oder auf dem
ipad selbst wenn ihr es wollt das kann
natürlich auch machen wir lustig seit
das spricht er mit dem entsprechenden
gewinne ab so dann komme das spiel ab
das spiel sieht so aus das hier ist
unser charakter liefern heißt er rief an
woran erinnert mich nie fand ich wollte
mir gerade was lustiges aus denken aber
es kam einfach nicht okay und hier links
hat man so verschiedene reihte da kann
man sich in verschiedene orte des spiels
gegeben zum beispiel hier oben links ist
die taverne das jetzt gar nicht hilft
die facetime darüber ist aber hier
sicher wären okay und hier wird dabei
haben wir so ein paar leute können wir
checken was die so machen
hier ist amazon ort dann ziemlich dumm
anschaut hier wie so ein kleiner mädchen
spieler so und so
was soll ich sagen und jetzt schickt
einfach die ganze zeit sein erster ab
gerade sonst würde nicht zum gesicht
machen ganz ehrlich hat dem er aber voll
mag glauben so thomas unterziehen okay
was willst du denn hier
sag mal bist du dich erst mal was tun
bevor laufen lässt ich mache nichts
sollte ich das video vor laufen übrigens
die leute die mich schon länger kennen
wissen dass ich immer extrem ehrlich mit
meinen zuschauern sein möchte meine
reichweite nicht missbrauchen möchte
deswegen werde ich euch das spiel
kritisch darstellen das heißt ich sage
was ich gut finde ich sage was ich
schlecht finde dass sie persönlich
wichtig ich habe meine meinung nicht
erkaufen lassen ich sage euch meinen
subjektiven eindruck und ja sag ich was
ich vor dem spiel halter mit gucken
jetzt mal hier okay also der ist ja wohl
gerade heftig mit starren beschäftigt
gast wird der ort für uns hat ich hoffe
dass ihr wissen moment noch in meine
aufträge sind für flüchtlinge schauen
was zu tun gibt aber wenn du angst hast
dann lass es lieber bleiben
so was hat er jetzt hier her mit dem
geld der insolvente händler eine leere
kiste mit dem geld hin gut ok belohnung
65.000 ist nicht schlecht aber was ihr
nicht seht was man auch wir haben
einfach eiskalt 75 millionen gold und
1700 pilze weil das in account ist den
mir die jungs vom platz zur verfügung
gestellt haben wir schon hoch gelevelt
damit ich quasi mich nicht wohl aber
muss man machen wir mal diese mission so
und so funktioniert das eben man hat
dann eine gewisse wartezeit die man
warten muss bis man sich in diese
mission begeben kann würde aber sagen
wir kennst du das mal und checken hier
drüben war die arena ab sodass seht ihr
hier
doch mal rein da kommen auch wieder die
jetzt haben wir gegner ok spieler mails
87 wie gegen mich in der arena kämpfen
was kann er so first drauf während sehen
okay wie man will fall mehr leben
und so funktioniert das kampfsystem hier
alles läuft vollautomatisch ich muss gar
nichts drücken alter habe ich sollte ihn
eigentlich packen oder blog malblock
blocken sieht gut aus ist sie gut aus
für uns oder wenn geblockt nein nein
nein
jawohl des jahres gepackt das war knapp
dahinter ist und schmutzigen tricks
konntest du den zwei kam am ende zu
deinen gunsten entscheiden
sehr schön dass man doch direkt nochmal
wenn das bock gemacht hat hier jetzt hat
man wieder so ein cooldown hier also das
spiel passiert sowieso ein browsergame
eine immer auf so cool downs und
wartezeiten und hier unten sehen wir
auch was ganz neues festung das ist
nämlich jetzt mit dem neuen update
erschienen zwar dass festungs update und
ich habe mir schon mal eine festung
gesetze die schon mal bauen lassen so
jetzt haben wir eine festung stufe 1 die
festung dient dem zweck dass sie quasi
die möglichkeit bieten dass der spieler
sich da eine eigenes haus aufbauen kann
ein eigenes zuhause und die gebäude die
umsetzung geben nämlich zum beispiel
hier in der schatzkammer eine akademie
die gebäude gebe die möglichkeit den
charakter noch weiter zu verbessern und
masken und mal holz verletzte nicole
borgmann kein fachmann sein charaktere
noch weiter zu verbessern und mit
zusätzlich zurück man sich das auch ganz
leise nur wir haben jetzt zu wenig gold
resourcen aok wir brauchen holz wir
brauchen steine gold haben auf jeden
fall genug der clou ist jetzt glaube ich
man muss es wahrscheinlich hier die
holzfäller hütte bauen
das dauert jetzt 15 minuten und eine
edelstahl sie etwas für stein braucht
man einen edelsteine oder wie ein
steinbruch befestigung können bauen
steinerne haut man kann auch nur einen
bau folge auf einmal laufen lassen das
heißt wir können jetzt nicht theoretisch
könnten marke bestehen noch mal eine
edelstein wieder aufbauen denn man kann
nur alles nicht auf alles auf einmal man
kann nur einen bau vorgang auf einmal
aufbauen gehen nochmal zurück bern wie
gesagt also diese optik spiel gefällt
mir relativ gut
auch der humor des spiels sagt mir zu
finde ich ganz cool werde gleich noch
sehen warum wenn wir nach ein paar
konkrete beispiele haben was mir nicht
gefällt da will ich auch ganz ehrlich
sind diese wartezeiten weil es
mittlerweile einfach gewohnt bin
das alles quasi im spiel direkt passiert
aber ich meine dass das browsergame
typisch wahrscheinlich geht früher auch
mal andere browser games gezockt da lief
das ganz ähnlich also man hat immer
diese wartezeiten glaube ich so was
gibt's hier unten ehrenhalle dungeons
wir haben eigene gilde dies hier perfekt
player ist die gilde maßnahmen reger
leute ich habe übrigens nebenbei noch
fragen auf twitter gestellt die wir
jetzt hier so parallel dazu beantworten
rund um das thema gaming und zwar die
erste folge kommt von der fragt was war
das erste videospiel was du jemals
gespielt hast ich glaube das erste
videospiel war
wenn wir jetzt um einen kampf an ihren
damals super mario brothers super mario
brothers auf dem gameboy color bei
meinem zahnarzt mainzern das hat er
damals und game boy color um mich herum
fliegen und damit hab ich das erste mal
das war mein erstes video spielt ist hat
man damals bekommen wir eine besonders
tapfer war bei der zahnbehandlung oder
wenn man lange warten musste das team
bekommen ich glaube das war mein erstes
spiel dann habe ich irgendein eigenen pc
bekommen habe ich am pc als münchen
gespielt gts endrias damals mit zehn
danke pop wissen wir dass wir gekauft
hast obwohl ich damals fing alles an
meine liebe für gta an
so here stadtwache da können wir
scheinbar wache schieben und kriegen
dafür gold so da kann man jetzt zum
beispiel sagen okay wir arbeiten zehn
stunden kriegen 109 millionen gold
bisschen guter stundenlohn 190000 gold
pro stunde das kann ihr versehen lassen
würde ich sagen dann gibt es hier auch
dieses dungeons feature da kann man in
verschiedene dungeons springer stores
daraus ist glaube ich auch so eine
kleine hommage an
game of thrones dreizehnter stock stein
will nicht raus
ich darf hier diese ganzen dungeons
wurden schon gemacht sagt er ist schon
übernachten dran aber wie stärkt jetzt
mal ab was hier in diesem 3 zehnten
stock abgeht
diese der pen trader aus einem der
verwüsteten büro hamas ein geräusch
gehört vor sich chancen nach es ist
bestimmt nichts weiter doch plötzlich
springt ja diese der pendler entgegen er
will dir ans leder mindestens also
dagegen kämpfen ums leben der hat google
app engine bergwelt richtig rein man wie
krank ist dieses wesen stufe 365 ist ein
paar 23 juli um keine chance wir sind
ihnen sind down easy peasy und notfalls
gegen den von diesem unbeholfen auftritt
einerseits werden sich die bewohner
lange beim lagerfeuer erzählen
schön verpackt und hier drüben wird
gerade unsere holzpalette gebaut werden
dann die holzpalette fertig ist können
wir uns wahrscheinlich holz machen so
und das holz nutzen um mir weitere
updates machen bzw die müssen wir
erstmal steinmetz bauen wahrscheinlich
für die steine hier unten da ist der
steinbruch okay gut da kommt es dem
bauern für nachher wildensteiner
brauchen genau so funktioniert es ja so
finanziert das spiel im allgemeinen was
was ist mein abschließende meinung habe
zu wenig zu der frage vorgelesen
eine frage haben wir auf jeden fall noch
mal rein oder zwei fragen die die
official fragt was macht für dich ein
gutes spiel aus atmosphäre auf jeden
fall atmosphäre gibt spiele die mir am
besten gefallen zum beispiel assassin's
creed oder gta zeichnen sich alle durch
eine atmosphäre aus beispiel die durch
eine gute story hergestellt wird durch
passende musik findet setting schöne
gebäude schöne umgebung ich hab jetzt
atmosphäre auf jeden fall atmosphäre
würde ich sagen will ich es atmosphäre
das wichtigste im spiel das man so
richtig rein versehen und sich
nachfolger einfühlen kann und dann noch
zum abschluss eine frage von sissi misty
seefahrt haben nun mag es auch mal
zusammen gezogen mit einer gestorben ist
wurde abgewechselt so war es bei uns
immer haha ja mehr oder weniger obwohl
es früher meistens so war dass ich immer
gesagt habe und max meistens zu sehen
musst du nicht spielen lassen ab
ich war früher als kind echten assi muss
man wirklich so sagen immer wieder
drüber aber okay andere geschichte wurde
so jetzt haben viel erzählt dass hier
gibt's zu gewinnen schatten die
kommentare warum iris gewinnen solltet
sucht dann den gewinner aus und der
kriegt signierte wenn er will
ja das war so weit von mir wenn ihr
jetzt interesse an dem spiel habt führt
der erste link in der beschreibung
direkt zu shakes and fidget das heißt
wenn nämlich der unterstützen wollt
klickt da drauf und schaue ich das mal
an wenn es für euch interessant das
wohlgemerkt müsst ja nicht machen
arbeitsbericht interessantes können das
machen ja das war so weit von mir wir
sind bei der nächsten folge wieder haut
rein macht's gut und